today on the matt walsh show the marine
corps hires a chief diversity officer as
it moves towards its goal of creating a
more diverse equitable and tolerant
force
that's the way they're selling it anyway
but today we'll talk about what that
really means also camila harris is upset
that she doesn't have enough to do as
vice president and now her team is
apparently accusing joe biden's team of
racism who could have possibly seen that
coming plus a michigan school is forced
to shut down because a large number of
staff members have an adverse reaction
to the covet booster that's pretty
inconvenient and as we discussed on
friday a college professor is on a
campaign to destigmatize pedophiles the
college has responded to the outrage and
britney spears is free
should we celebrate should we care at
all we'll talk about that and so much
more today on the matt walsh show
the washington post reports that china
is currently in the process of
modernizing and diversifying
its fleet of nuclear warheads the
defense department now expects that
china's arsenal will have quadrupled
within the next decade by 2030 the
communist nation should have more than a
thousand nuclear warheads among them
will be a certain number of hypersonic
orbital missiles which can circle the
globe without being detected and of
course that's not new technology and
china still will have fewer nuclear
nuclear weapons than we do i mean enough
to destroy the entire planet so probably
that's sufficient uh but we'll still
have more but the point though is that
they seem focused on
strengthening their position and
becoming a more formidable global force
while we have
well other priorities in an interview
with npr general david berger
announced that the marine corps will be
overhauling and reinventing itself in
order to institute more diversity not
nuclear diversity but the type of
diversity that politically correct hr
representatives are worried about
reading from yahoo news it says
according to berger marines will work to
quote reflect america to reflect the
society we come from adding that the
decision is not one related to being
woke or politically correct
sure whatever you say quote our
advantage militarily is on top of our
shoulders burger said it's not actually
our equipment we are better than anybody
else primarily because we don't all
think exactly alike we didn't come from
the same backgrounds
now far be it for me it's a question the
esteemed general um
i didn't serve in the military
i never fought in any war i admit that
even so i'm skeptical that any military
engagement has ever been won due to a
due to you know diversity of ethnic
backgrounds among the victors
can anybody point me to an example for
military history
of a battle that was won
um because of diversity
i'm trying to imagine back say during
the normandy invasion a group of
soldiers pinned down taking heavy enemy
fire
one of them shouts we need someone with
a diverse ethnic background over here
stat
it's hard for me to picture that
you know i i can't see why that would
have specifically helped
but the marines are all in on their
diversity plan anyway in fact as fox
news reports they're paying big bucks to
make this happen quote uh from the
report a job listing with the u.s marine
corps seeking a diversity equity and
inclusion advisor with a starting salary
of 144 thousand dollars is gaining
attention on social media the usmc is
hiring the advisor to ensure that quote
all internal and external communications
reflect diversity equity and inclusion
or dei and to develop tools that enable
shifting the usmc cultural paradigm for
diversity equity and inclusion
the dei advisor will work in
collaboration with the chief diversity
officer and the diversity review board
the listing states
duties include the assessment of
diversity and inclusion program
effectiveness design and lead implement
implementation of process improvement
initiatives
and provide executive level consultation
i don't know what any of that means as
well as the development and
administering of training and education
guidance to the cdo
it says quote you will drive strategic
management concepts and principles
including assisting with the development
of marine corps policy supporting the
usmc's mission vision values strategic
goals and objectives according to the
listing
now needless to say 144 000 a year is
significantly more
than any of the men
out actually doing the fighting are
getting paid
so risk your life for your country and
get paid about the same as i don't know
papa john's ship shift supervisor or
less
but sit behind a desk developing equity
and inclusion strategies
and you know that's where the big bucks
are made
at any rate if you want more information
on our military's diversity plans you'll
be happy to know that you can go to the
marine corps association website and
download their full
diversity equity and inclusion plan as
written by lieutenant general david
otignon and brigadier general jason
woodworth here you'll find details about
what this chief diversity officer will
do
and you can learn about the formation of
the aforementioned diversity review
board which the marines will be using as
they strive to achieve their diversity
goals and this is not just about racial
diversity of course as they explain
quote today's marine corps is 58 white
and 42 minority from 2010 to 2020
enlisted diversity grew from 33 to over
45 percent and our officer diversity
grew from 16 to 34
female diversity continues to climb each
year and is currently over 9
these are signs that we are making
positive progress but much but much work
remains to be done to retain and promote
a more diverse equitable and inclusive
force across all ranks
now again we must ask the question from
before
in the whole history of military
conflict
across the entire globe
has there ever been a battle won because
one side was more inclusive and
equitable than the other
i don't think so
in fact battles have been won with the
exact opposite approach
rather than diversity
militaries have always valued
cohesiveness
uniformity
that's why units march in formation
that's why we call them units
it's why they literally wear things
called uniforms
individuality has never been emphasized
instead it's been subordinated
ruthlessly sometimes to the needs of the
unit the group the whole
as for inclusiveness and equity our
military was a formidable fighting force
a two-time world champion
because it set standards for itself that
excluded those who were unfit
those who couldn't hack it
the military has never been a democracy
it's never been a place for individual
expression
it has never been a beacon of tolerance
or equality the military is a hierarchy
all militaries are hierarchies
there is no equality or equity in a
hierarchy there can't be
there's never been a democratic military
there's never been a tolerant military
there's never been anything like what
they are currently turning it into right
now
so once again we see that the left's
project
is to demolish deconstruct and
fundamentally rebuild and redefine
everything every american institution
every organization every tradition
every word every idea
terms like politically correct and woke
don't really even begin to capture
what's actually happening in our country
and what these people intend to do to it
one other point worth reiterating
it's important when we engage with these
ideas like diversity and inclusion that
we don't make the mistake of accepting
the premise that the left actually wants
diversity and inclusion
i mean that would be bad enough if that
is what they wanted diversity and
inclusion are terrible goals in and of
themselves
especially for a military
but really for any institution diversity
and inclusion should never be the
priority and if they were the real
priorities here there there would be
plenty to criticize about that but we
should also keep in mind that all of
these words diversity inclusion equity
tolerance etc they are all code for get
rid of white males
i mean that's that's really what this is
about
after all when they talk about
increasing the percentages of some
demographics
um
you know demographics that are not white
and male what that means is reducing the
percentage of white males just basic
math there
the goal of the military right now is
not just to get more black people and
women involved
because if the participation rates of
blacks and women grew and the
participation of white males grew at the
same time and at the same rate
you wouldn't see an increase in the
former group in terms of percentage
but they're talking about percentage
which means that the military very
specifically wants to drive white males
out
so they they frame it in a positive way
oh we want a greater percentage of this
group
but they could just as easily say we
want fewer of this group
we want fewer of those types
and you know the very group that's done
most of the fighting and dying for this
country the military wants them gone
thank you for your service now get out
this point is often made pretty explicit
when the topic of diversity comes up
take for instance this conversation on
msnbc over the weekend about now this
isn't diversity in the military this is
diversity in the trucking industry and
they've made it very clear what it's uh
what they're really concerned about
listen
you hear i have to tell you my brother
is a truck driver um and he drives
across the country and it's very uh
nerve-wracking to me uh when he's on the
road um
because it's just it feels like a
dangerous industry but you're trying to
disrupt that and bring more people who
look like us to the industry tell us why
yes ma'am first of all thank you for
having me this morning and yes we are
and we say we're not building truck
drivers but safe cmb operators folks
that can get back to their home whenever
they're done with their ship that's the
most important part man
well how can the industry be more
welcoming because i have to tell you i
talked to a lot of truck drivers and uh
preparing for this segment and um most
of these truck drivers were people of
color and they talked about um you know
hearing some of the racism um over the
cb um you know this is again an industry
populated um by a lot of white men over
the age of 55 um this group of people
overwhelmingly voted for trump um some
people have talked about you know
aggressive truck drivers uh cutting them
off or not being helpful um so obviously
the more populated it is with people of
color i think you'll see less of that
but how can you encourage people to come
and disrupt this space
when it seems a bit unwelcoming
well i think just what you're doing
getting uh myself as a black female out
there and letting people know i drove
for almost eight years and yes ran into
lots of racism but however was out there
to do my job and i think that uh women
are definitely the more we can just get
the news out to them that trucking is an
industry that will not only help them to
get further in life but their family and
all that and present the package to them
appropriately regardless of what anybody
else has to say they're going to be in
charge they're going to be the person
behind that steering wheel doing the job
every single day and making it happen
just out and out racism
i mean we're used to it by now
you picked up of course where she said
uh there's a lot of white males over 55
and people complain about um they're
sometimes aggressive and rude so
obviously if we have more people of
color as truck drivers there will be
less of that kind of behavior
right oh yeah well obviously white
people are more rude and aggressive she
says really do you have any
data on that
let me see the statistics on that
but um yes this is why women haven't
flocked to the trucking industry
every day i meet another woman whose
deepest desire is to be a long-haul
trucker driving a big rig across the
country spending her nights sleeping in
the cab in the back of a walmart parking
lot showering in gas stations
now this is what they most fervently
want but they aren't doing it because
the trucking industry is sexist
i mean i i like i said every day i meet
another woman with that story don't you
what i really wanted to be was a
long-haul trucker they all say
my wife too she tells me all the time
what she always wanted as a young girl
was to you know get in that truck drive
across the desert
now the msnbc anchor speaks with disdain
about those uh white males over 55 who
drive trucks the ones who make sure that
she has food to eat and clothes to wear
i mean her lifestyle depends on those
men but she hates them
rather than saying thank you
which is what you should be that's what
you're missing here
you see a lot of people on the left
never had had never had parents to tell
them what do you say you say thank you i
gotta say with my kids all the time you
know i hand them a snack
what do you say thank you
well to this msnbc anchor what do you
say you say thank you to the white males
or making your life easier we're
allowing you to live by providing all of
these things to you
but rather than saying thank you uh she
wants them she wants them gone she wants
them jobless and homeless that's how she
feels
that's what all this diversity and
inclusion stuff is really about it's an
anti-white male conspiracy first and
foremost
and in the process it strips people of
their humanity and it reduces them to
statistics a white person driving a
truck is not a person according to msnbc
he is a faceless representative for his
race which is running a surplus
you know the white person supply exceeds
the white person demand at least
according to the corporate media
there must be a white person clearance
sale so that we can clean our shelves
and restock them with more valuable
racial merchandise
this is essentially how our social
engineers view the problem
which is only a problem in the first
place because they've decided to call it
one
you know the problem of there being a
lot of white males over 55 driving
trucks
there's no it's not a problem at all
but they've decided that it's a
problem but if we're really worried
about fighting racism and inequality
then the goal should be a society where
a person can
live where they want
work where they want if they're
qualified pursue whatever opportunity
they want
go to school where they want
again if they qualify on the merits to
go to school
without anyone caring about their skin
color or their ethnic background
you know in this scenario a man would be
judged on his merits alone and he would
climb as far in life as those merits
will take him
but that's not how our society operates
because that's not what the proponents
of forced diversity want
they want division resentment and racism
and that's what they've gotten
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now quick word from moiq listen stop
arguing with your friends about politics
and do something join the moiq movement
and save the family farm well that's
what it says on the copy but really i
think you can still argue about politics
because i enjoy that too much we can do
both why can't we do both with moic you
get the highest quality meat you've ever
tasted while supporting real family
farms at the same time moich delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and wild
caught alaskan salmon directly to your
door helping family farms become
financially independent outside of big
agriculture their animals are raised
outdoors their fish swim wild in the
ocean and monk meat is free of
antibiotics hormone sugar and all the
other junk you find in pre-packaged
stuff that you buy in the meat aisle at
the grocery store don't bother with that
get a moiq box today sign up at
mointbox.com walsh to get a year of
ground beef for free and then pick what
meats you want delivered with your first
box change what you what you uh what you
get each month and cancel anytime moique
was founded by an eighth generation
farmer who was featured on shark tank
and the guys in shark tank loved it um i
love it as well that's what really
matters here so join the movement today
go to moicbox.com
walsh right now and listen and listeners
to this show get free ground beef for a
year that's one year of the best ground
beef you'll ever taste for a limited
time spelled m o i n k box dot com slash
walsh that's box dot com welsh
well my pillow's been a big supporter of
this show we're very grateful for that
and for the wonderful products that make
it so easy to sleep at night
but my pillow they want to give back to
our listeners even more you can get
great discounts on all my pillow
products if you go to mypillow.com right
now and click on the radio listener
special get deep discounts on my pillows
mattress toppers towels and so much more
for example my pillow is offering a buy
one get one free offer on giza dream bed
sheets these are top quality sheets that
you will love and like with all the
other my pillow products once you use
those products you're not going to want
to use any others all my pillow products
come with a 60-day money-back guarantee
and a 10-year warranty go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listener special for the buy one get one
free offer on the giza sheets and use
promo code daily wire check out or call
800-651-1148 you'll also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including pillows slippers the my pillow
mattress topper and my pillow towel sets
all that stuff that's mypillow.com and
enter dailywire or call 1-800-651-1148
and tell them dailywire sent you that's
1-800-651-1148 these deals won't last
forever so get them now oh man i'm in a
tough spot it's uh what is it november
what is november 15th
so guess where i was on saturday i was
walking around a christmas store looking
at christmas decorations
and uh we were taking and the kids were
you know we took the kids to see santa
in mid-november
my wife's already said that the whole
house is gonna be decorated this week
she was threatening to do it today
actually so i might come home and the
whole house is decorated for christmas
it's of course way too early uh to be
doing any of this but it's it's my fault
because i told my wife a few months ago
that the twins are now at the age where
and i'm i'm trying to be uh put this
carefully and be delicate because i
don't know if there's any young ears
listening right now
but the twin what i was saying to my
wife few months ago that the twins are
at an age where it might be time to have
a difficult conversation
about santa claus with them
and i wanted to do it right then on the
spot
i told my you know again i i probably
this was probably too sudden but you
know the kids were in the other room and
i said this to my wife and i said i'm
going right now this is happening we're
doing this right now ripping the
band-aid off
and she uh she pleaded with me and she
was saying you know
we got to give the kids one more magical
christmas one more christmas with santa
before we destroy their hopes and dreams
forever and so i relented which just
means that she's gonna milk this
christmas for all it's worth it's gonna
be christmas on steroids i mean we're
gonna
we're gonna end up doing like a world
tour of mall santas
uh my wife is treating this christmas
like she's on death row and this is her
last meal except it's really santa on
death row death threat i mean that's
that's what's happening
and i know
i know some of you are listening to this
right now and you're saying well see
this is why you shouldn't do the santa
thing at all this is this is what this
is why what i my family when i when i
have kids we're not going to tell them
about santa
yeah you say that
but you don't know what it's like out
there especially if you don't have kids
or if you have kids who are older and
and you know it was a long time ago
maybe you've forgotten
so you don't understand
there is no the whole debate among
parents about uh are we doing the santa
thing or not
it's a moot point
because there is no doing santa or not
doing santa that choice is taken from
you if you live in society now if you
live on a homestead somewhere if you
live in or if you you know if you live
in the wilderness if you're if you're
removed from society which is a great
plan by the way
but in that case then yeah you could
choose what you want to do about santa
but if you live in in
mainstream society
you don't have that choice
he he santa's everywhere
he he really does see you when you're
sleeping and know when you're awake he's
everywhere the kids just pick him up on
their own
and they pick him up at the same age
when they believe in things like
spider-man yeah they think spider-man is
real
and they think unicorns are real and
dragons and fairies and all that
so santa exists in the same realm
as all of those things
so if you really want to make sure the
kids don't believe in santa then what
you really have to do
because you're not gonna they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna encounter
santa and they're gonna put them in the
same categories all these other things
in their imagination they think is real
so if you want to make sure they don't
do santa you have to take all of it away
from a young age
spider-man dragons fairies you got to
take it all
if you re so from a young
age from like the age of three you have
to say to your kids none of it's real
this is all fake
stop believing in this stuff
and you have to continue hammering that
home
and if you don't do that then your kids
are just going to believe it
and that's the way it goes
until you get to a point where it's like
okay now it's a little bit too old and
uh so now you really have because
because the other things like dragons
and fairies they'll kind of
they'll grow out of that on their own
but they'll they'll hang on to santa and
so that's when inevitably you have to
have the conversation
all right
camila harris let's go to uh someone
else kamela harris has a
sort of a fictional character herself in
many ways
and she has a certain way about her
every time she's giving a speech
she sounds like she's reading from a
book report where she had to stretch
to hit the to hit the word count and if
i sound like i'm i'm speaking from
experience i am this is like me through
12 years of grade school every book
report any assignment this this is what
i did
you know you try you put in as many
superfluous words as you need you try to
mess with the margins and the font a
little bit thinking that you're the
first you know every kid thinks of that
you think you're the first one to come
up oh i know i'll make it the 12.5 font
instead of 12 font teacher will never
see that
um so i did this a lot myself and camila
harris is i'm not going to say she's a
master at it but she
she certainly has quite a lot of
experience so here she is
giving a speech in france and uh let's
let's listen
we must together work together
to see where we are where we are headed
where we are going and our vision for
where we should be
but also see it as a moment yes
to
together address the challenges
and to work on the opportunities
we must together work together
with togetherness
and together we must together move
forward and
also together go forward while we're
moving forward and together
make plans for the future
and for what will come
and for tomorrow
together
all together
so that we can be together today
and tomorrow
and into the future
together
in our togetherness
that's uh that's kind of that speech is
is camilla harris
in a nutshell
and it also explains i think why uh
she's not very popular
because she she's some she is so phony
that she makes she makes hillary clinton
seem authentic by comparison she makes
hillary clinton seem like a fully
fleshed
fleshed-out sort of uh
human being by comparison
and that's why people don't like her
um because it's a it's it's not even a
choice really
as human beings ourselves
we don't make a decision
to like someone or not like them when we
pick up on in inauthenticity phoniness
it's a visceral reaction
um
and i guess camille harris's team
they've picked up on this and nobody
likes her and so that is what led to
this cnn headline over the weekend
exasperation and dysfunction inside
kamela harris's frustrating start as
vice president
and you go through and she's complaining
a lot about how people don't like her
and maybe off the record her team is
complaining off the right mostly off the
record um people don't like her there's
not a lot for her to do
i mean that part of it like that's what
you signed up for that's the job is
you're the vice president that's it's
it's a totally ceremonial thing
um you're you're about as useless as the
first lady
so you think you know that going in
but then it's a whole long story um
talking about this and the and the
tension between the different camps and
everything and camilla harris wants to
be wants to be more in the spotlight
than she is
wow big shocker there
and then we get to this
this just one part from the piece that i
want to read to you
and though harris has told confidance
that she has been enjoying a good
working dynamic directly with biden
those who work for them describe their
relationship in terms of settling into
an exhausted stalemate
suspicion has sprouted out of the
bitterness last month white house aides
leapt to the defense of transportation
secretary pete boudegic who is being
hammered with outrage by fox news host
tucker carlson a like-minded online
pundits for taking paternity leave after
the adoption of his twins in september
harris loyalists tell cnn
they see in that yet another example of
an unfair standard at play wondering why
she didn't get similar cover any of the
times that she's been attacked by the
right
quote this is a former harris aide
speaking of the record it's hard to miss
the specific energy that the white house
defends it brings to defend a white man
knowing that camille harris has spent
almost a year taking a lot of the hits
that the west wing didn't want to take
themselves
so that
these are the first rumblings from
someone in harris's camp accusing joe
biden of racism
um
he was always destined to come to this
it's destined to come to this no matter
what
this is why left-wing
governance is is always going to be
dysfunctional one of the many reasons
why it's always going to be
dysfunctional because there's always
going to be
you know the the various identity groups
uh uh competing with one another
trying to climb the ladder to be the
uber victim i mean that's that's all
intersectionality that's all built in
but also camila harris
really her whole democratic primary
platform
was
accusing joe biden of racism
that was her whole deal her one moment
in the sun
you know where she went from one percent
in the polls to like two and a half
percent and she was it was the camille
harris surge
that's when she got up there during the
democratic primary debates and accused
of a big
segregationist
and then joe biden makes a decision to
bring her into the white house and uh
shockingly she's now accusing him of
racism
um and then there's bitterness too
because
you know pete buttage is there and you
know he he he's going to want to run in
2024 assuming that joe biden doesn't run
which is maybe
um
i'm not sure how safe of
an assumption that really is
i mean would he run at the age of 82
sure he would
partly he would run because he's not
going to have any idea what he's doing
at that point he hardly has any idea
what he's doing now
it's it's i i suppose what we really
should ask is would
joe biden's handlers
push him to run at the age of 82
as at that point a full-on vegetable
probably they will
but whether it's um
you know 24 or 28 pete buttegage is also
you know
wants to be the heir apparent
and so again we have this
intersectionality tension between the
two
are we going to have the first woman
president or the first uh the first gay
president
what which
it's really going to be up to the
democratic party
who are they going to throw their weight
behind
who's going to get the coronation
and uh and i could
i think we can assume
that it's going to be bootage
i'm in fact i will put that prediction
on the record right now that i think we
will have the first gay president
uh before we have the first woman
president
because that identity simply takes
priority on the left it's as simple as
that
as a woman you are i hate to say it if
you're on the left and you're jocking
for position on the victimhood pyramid
you're pretty far down the the scale
i got to say you're pretty far down the
totem pole to keep mixing uh metaphors
here
so i think yeah i think i think they're
going to go with budage
based on the identity points he said he
has more identity points than camilla
harris does
sadly for her all right next i really
like this clip this is a great clip a
chinese activist a dissident former
political prisoner was interviewed on
pbs
and he's been speaking out against
authoritarianism in the united states
and he's been warning about
authoritarian authoritarianism in the
united states the interviewer mark
margaret hoover
has him on
hoping that he'll talk about donald
trump and how donald trump is an
authoritarian
but that's not exactly how things go
let's listen
in your book
you're describing the directives of mao
zedong during the cultural revolution
that would be distributed publicly every
night and then you write this is your
quote they served
a function similar to donald trump's
late night tweets while in office
they were the direct communication of a
leader's thoughts to his devoted
followers enhancing the sanctity of his
authority
so
do you see donald trump as an
authoritarian
i
well i don't you know he if you are
authoritarian you have to have a system
in supporting you you cannot just being
authoritarian by yourself
but certainly
in united states with today's
condition
you can easily have authoritarian
in many ways you're already
in the authoritarian state
you just don't know it
how so
many things happens today in u.s
it can be compared cultural revolution
in china
like what
like people trying to be
unified in certain political correctness
that is very dangerous
you gotta you have to see the clip
uh
while listening to it to really fully
appreciate it because the interviewer
poor margaret there you can see her kind
of inner eye she's dying inside as she
sees that this is not going in the
direction she wanted it to go
uh she wants to talk about donald trump
as the tyrannical threat even though
he's
not even in office anymore
and instead this chinese political
activist dissident says its political
correctness
is why we live in authoritarian state
and the reason that he gives is very
insightful uh no surprise that he has
insight into this given where he's where
he's coming from now
um and the experience he has
but authoritarianism tyranny it's all
about systems there has to be a system
in place
donald trump never had a system whatever
you
how do you feel about donald trump as a
person
um whatever you think his own personal
instincts are
he was never any kind of threat
to be a you know a despotic tyrannical
dictator ruling america with an iron
fist
even if he would have liked to do that
and i don't think he would have liked to
do that i don't think that's what he was
he was all about but he never had the
system in place
the system was against him the entire
time
there's no question about that
the system was trying to destroy donald
trump the whole time that he was on
ostensibly on top of it and supposed to
be running it
so that was never a threat
whatever his own instincts might have
been it was never a threat
um but political correctness and as i
said in the opening
you know these are the labels the terms
that we use political correctness
wokeness
uh it's kind of for lack of a better
term i don't love the terms because
they they tend to sort of understate the
threat
but even so these are the terms that we
have right now so people know what we're
talking about and political correctness
leftism woke-ism all these things
wrapped together they have the system
that's what i always say about cancel
culture
there there is no right-wing cancel
culture
even if there are people on the right
who would like to have one i mean i have
something called the daily cancellation
so if i could run my own canceled
culture i would take it
but um i don't have the system
cancel culture is a function of the
system and that is why cancel culture is
inherently a left-wing phenomenon and
it's all wrapped up with whatever you
want to call political correctness
wellness all these things together
they have the
system and so the authoritarian threat
is entirely from the left
because they have the system and when we
talk about the system what do we mean we
mean
government the state we mean uh
academia media hollywood corporate
america
all of the most powerful institutions in
the country
are all on the same side
wanting to suppress a particular point
of view
and particular groups of people
all right next what do we got here um i
got to play this for you this is a local
news report out of michigan
[Music]
and to be honest with you i'm not even
sure if
i don't know if if in playing this it
means that this youtube this is gonna be
this show will be taken off of youtube i
don't know but this is a news report a
local news report out of michigan
let's uh let's listen
covet 19 pandemic weighing heavy on some
michigan school districts some districts
have had to close entirely because of
outbreaks of the virus while others only
partially as our mark bouillon shows us
today it was something other than covet
19 that forced one saginaw county school
district to close their doors today
saginaw township community schools
closed for today at first you might be
thinking covet 19 is to blame but a
district spokesperson tells me a large
number of staff members had negative
reactions to the covid19 booster they
received over the weekend
now according to the cdc some of the
most common side effects of the pfizer
and moderna covet booster are pain at
the injection site fatigue muscle pain
headache and fever also the chills and
nausea for the j j booster the cdc says
fever fatigue and headache were some of
the more common symptoms
recent data from the cdc shows among 12
500 people who received a third dose of
the covid19 vaccine 79 percent reported
those local reactions like pain and
itching at the injection site while 74
percent reported the systemic reactions
like muscle pain and fatigue
now going back to the district they also
say what complicates the situation even
more is the substitute teacher shortage
which is why the district had to
completely shut down you may remember
just last week swan valley schools had
to close also because of a staffing
shortage
in saginaw county mark bullion abc 12
news
now you do have to account for the
possibility that i mean these are
teachers we're talking about and one
thing we know about teachers and this
certainly has been this point has been
underscored over the last uh 18 months
to two years teachers don't love working
it's not their favorite thing to do
and so they'll take advantage of any of
any opportunity you give them to call
out of work
and so you have to account for that i
mean there's probably going to be a
certain number of teachers who
uh when they found out that they could
get a couple days paid vacation for
claiming adverse reactions they decided
to go ahead and do that
um but even so
you know unless you want to chalk all
this up to that which i wouldn't
this is a this is a school
shutting down
reportedly
because of adverse reactions to the
covent booster
and there have been many more maybe not
schools shutting down but there have
been many reports of people having
adverse reactions to the booster those
are the reports
youtube that's what the reports say
and so we're gonna get this is something
we have to keep in mind because we are
certainly going just like ron desantis
warned about a few weeks ago and he's
exactly right
that we're going to get to the point
very soon and this is relevant to the
biden vaxx mandate that we are fighting
back against uh here at the daily wire
and one of the reasons why it's so
important for us to fight back against
it
is that um
you know even if you're vaccinated
pretty soon you're not gonna be
vaccinated vaccinated anymore at least
according to
the standards set by
you know the government and uh and
different employers
we're going to get to a point pretty
soon where they're going to say well if
you got the double
if you were double vaxxed
uh a year ago or eight months ago or ten
months ago uh that that doesn't count
anymore as being fully vaccinated
we know that the goal post for fully
vaccinated continues to shift and shift
and shift and shift and it probably will
never stop shifting
so this is going to be a perpetually
moving target where if you want to be
fully vaccinated it means you have to
keep getting the booster shots
which means potentially what they're
saying is if you want to be fully
vaccinated it means every six months
potentially you got to go and get a shot
that might make you sick
for a couple of days and so you have to
intentionally
essentially make yourself sick every six
months
to avoid getting this other sickness
that for most people
will be
[Music]
mild to moderate or you might not have
any symptoms at all
total madness
speaking of madness a quick update here
that i think is worth mentioning this is
from wk wtkr local news old dominion
university released a statement after
one of his assistant professors gave a
controversial interview defending people
attracted to children
i wouldn't even call it controversial
there's no controversy
assumes that there's a position to be
you know you could stake out a position
on either side of it and argue about it
there's no real controversy here
this was a
professor alan walker
who wanted to destigmatize pedophilia no
controversy
that is
horrendous disgusting evil
any other adjective along those lines
you want to use no controversy there at
least there shouldn't be
uh but walker is an assistant professor
of sociology and criminal justice at old
dominion university
the interview as you remember we talked
about this in the opening on friday the
interview revolved around
walker's book a long it's called a long
dark shadow minor attracted people and
their pursuit of dignity that's what the
book is about being interviewed by this
creepy prestasia foundation that again
as you remember is an organization that
is committed to destigmatizing
pedophilia and doing it under the
auspices of protecting children by
destigmatizing
uh pedophilia
so there was outrage about this
well-deserved outrage
and finally old dominion university
released a statement here's their
statement
again a statement about one of their
professors on their payroll
openly trying to destigmatize pedophilia
here's what they have to say about it
an academic community plays a valuable
role in the quest for knowledge a vital
part of this is being willing to
consider scientific and other empirical
data that may involve controversial
issues and perspectives
following a recent interview that gained
national attention dr alan walker has
released the following statement
i want to be clear child sexual abuse is
an inexcusable crime as an assistant
professor of sociology and criminal
justice the goal of my research is to
prevent crime my work is informed by my
past experience and advocacy as a social
worker counseling victims i embarked on
this research in hopes of gaining
understanding of a group that previously
has not been studied in order to
identify ways to protect children
following recent social media activity
and direct outreach to the institution
it is important to share that old
dominion as a caring and inclusive
community does not endorse or promote
crimes against children or any form of
criminal activity that's it that's the
study if you're waiting for the part
where there's any sort of apology or if
they're going to say that they're
getting rid of this alan walker
degenerate scumbag
no that's not going to happen
no apology
the most we get is uh well old dominion
does not endorse or promote crimes
against children by the way if you find
yourself in a position
where
you have to say that
where you have to stipulate that you
don't endorse or promote sexual crimes
against children
then that should tell you something
you know that means you you have you
have veered very far from the from the
uh from the decent path here if you have
to clarify that at all
but they're not going to apologize
they're not going to get rid of
this professor
now if this professor had
made a tick tock video i don't know
wearing a maga hat
or something
be a holy totally different deal right
there'd be an apology there would be
statements there would be this and that
the person would be fired put on
administrative leave at least
but this goes back to what
we just heard about the the nature of
tyranny in the united states it's all
about who controls the systems
the left controls the system and the
system has no interest
in
force forcefully condemning people who
promote pedophilia
in fact the system has an interest in
the opposite
because really the system agrees with
alan walker
that all sexual choices and sexual quote
unquote lifestyles should be uh should
ultimately be de-stigmatized
accepted tolerated that's how the system
feels about it
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
all right before we get to the uh to the
comments here from the sweet baby gang
it's um i think this is a good
opportunity to tell you
that we are going to be hiring on the
matt walsh shows pretty exciting uh we
have we need an intern on the show
basically to be my slave for for slave
labor
um
you will
not be actually you will be paid so it's
not really a slave position at all i was
hoping that you would be what i wanted
was that i wanted like slave labor but i
was told that for a lot of different
reasons hr reasons you can't really have
a slave so instead uh we're gonna it's
gonna be a paid internship position if
you wanna be an intern on the daily on
the uh on the matt wall show go to
dailywire.com scroll to the bottom for
the intern link
and fill out the application
all right let's go to the comments this
is from todd says maybe map
could simultaneously stand for millstone
attached person
well done wish i had thought of that
melanie says been listening to you for a
while now all the times you talk about
hookup culture or topics surrounding
that make me think deeply
i've struggled with my impulsive habits
when it comes to sex and everything you
say makes the clearest sense possible
it's fun for like a second getting that
super attractive guy in bed but then
afterward when i'm inevitably left in
the dust the emptiness and pain of using
and being and being used will never be
worth it all this promotion of casual
sex is absolutely unfounded and
delusional i've been part of that
promotion for a long time but now i am
so completely over this illusion and
working hard to not fall into that void
anymore so thank you for helping me well
thank you for that comma melanie and
this is the um
like they say with anything right the
first the first step is
is i don't know what is it the first
step is acceptance or something maybe no
no acceptance is not what you want but
realizing the situation that you're in
and confronting it i think the first
step is confrontation i think
um
because
this is this is kind of the irony of
hookup culture that
everybody
involved in it
feels basically the same way that you do
whether they can articulate those
thoughts or not and many of them can't
and that's a big part of the problem
that again they don't have the moral
language to understand their own
feelings or articulate them
but everyone feels the same way uh no
one is happy
nobody can live a life like that for any
length of time and feel very happy and
fulfilled by it because we're human
beings
and there are certain things that we
need beyond just the basic physical
needs
you need connection with other human
beings
companionship i mean these are these are
real needs
and we're just being used as a glorified
sex toy which is what happens in hookup
culture then you're not you're not
having that deeper need fulfilled and uh
you're start you you see that and that's
um
that's a step in the right direction
all right savatch says i love how south
park creators trey stone and matt parker
have never been hailed as courageous or
revolutionary despite them attending the
2000 oscars in dresses while also high
on acid that took courage
well yeah a lot of people bring that up
whenever we have one of these guys
showing up to an award show now in the
year 2021 wearing a dress and feeling
like they're very bold and courageous
most recent one who is the guy the
rapper i forget his name now um did that
last week and every time that comes up
there's always people in the comments
bringing up the the south park guys who
did the same thing
to i think what was it the oh those the
oscars okay in 2000
but the big difference is that back then
you would have guys doing that
uh dennis rodman was the same when he
was married to carmen electra for two
seconds that he wore a wedding dress to
his wedding
but the whole idea was that it was
supposed to be absurd
and funny especially for the south park
guys
it was you know yeah you've always had
that like this cross-dressing thing
and there have always been guys doing
that
but very often in the past insaner times
it was comedy it's supposed to be funny
made a whole movie about it mrs
doubtfire with robin williams
and all of the comedy in that movie is
that robin williams is a dad dressed up
like like an old woman isn't that
hilarious
the difference now is that uh what was
once funny were supposed to take
seriously
we're supposed to look at it without
cracking a smile
and applaud and say uh this is this is a
very serious thing look at that man in
that dress looking like he's wearing his
sister's clothes
very serious yes so let's applaud him
um
let's see another one says during the
cancellation when matt brought up the
government taking care of the elderly
all of all that i could think about was
the horse and animal farm that was loyal
what did they do when he died they sold
him to a glue factory
yeah animal farm another
you know of orwell's books i think
animal farm
i see more of our current
condition in animal farm even than i see
in 1984.
um
let's see
mind traveler says the use of fictional
and fantasy scenarios as a means of
child protection makes sense from a
freudian perspective after all if
repression leads to greater depravity
one could almost consider it a moral
imperative to allow pedo's outlets for
their vice where no child is harmed
however from a classical christian point
of view where vices only gets stronger
the more they're fed the moral
imperative would of course be to burn
that sick filth wherever you find it i'm
a loyal viewer of the show so i suppose
you know where i stand
yeah well this is that's the classical
christian point of view
that if you feed a vice it will grow
stronger as you point out
just like with anything else
if you feed or fuel anything then you
are then you are strengthening it
um that's the classical christian point
of view
it's also the common sense point of view
it's also a point of view that has a you
know some some
uh intuition into the human condition
into how the human mind works
so this is another area one of many
where the christian moral intuition is
completely vindicated
uh so thanks for pointing that out
as you are well aware everything is more
expensive these days living is more
expensive than it's uh been for probably
any of us in our lifetime
which means that any opportunity you
have to save money you should take
advantage of it especially when it's as
easy as this the get upside app if you
use the get upside app my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code walsh and get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
walsh to get up to 50 cents a gallon
cashback on your first tank and then 25
cents a gallon cash back on all the
tanks after that some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch the cash is added to
your your account it's as simple as that
you can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal e-gift card for amazon
and other brands it really is that easy
no reason not to do it just download the
free get upside app and use promo code
walsh to get up to 50 cents a gallon
cashback on your first tank that's code
walsh
and also as the legacy media continues
to report their version of the news our
newest podcast morning wire continues
topping the apple and spotify charts and
we are continuing our continuing our
commitment to bringing you the news
without a hidden agenda it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending towards number one so
subscribe start listening right now to
morningwire on applespotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts and leave a
five-star review if you like what you
hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
sunday was another sad day in san
francisco two more walgreens stores
closed up shop another location will
close later this week
these are among a string of closings in
the city 22 walgreens have closed
already due to the effective
decriminalization of shoplifting in the
state a representative from one of the
local walgreens branches and the city
said in a statement to abc quote due
largely to ongoing organized retail
theft we have made the difficult
decision to close five stores across san
francisco five more stores anyway each
store will transfer prescriptions to a
nearby walgreens location within a mile
radius and we expect to place the stores
team members in other nearby locations
organized retail theft continues to be a
challenge facing retailers across san
francisco and we are not immune to that
retail theft across our san francisco
stores has continued to increase in the
past few months to five times our chain
average
now walgreens is not the only chain
affected the safeway location in the
city was recently forced to cut its
hours due to off the charts quote
unquote shoplifting now that store had
been open 24 hours but it's just not
possible to run a 24-hour operation in a
city where theft is legal you know
i mean we've seen how bad it could be in
the middle of the day now imagine a.m
how bad it must be so now that store
will close at 9 p.m each night which
means lots of employees at that location
will we can assume lose their jobs
a target store also closed recently for
the same reason and it's not just big
chains being slammed either every day it
seems there's another video of somebody
walking into a random local store
somewhere in the city
and walking out with armfuls of
merchandise here's the latest footage
from some boutique shop in in town we'll
watch this
[Music]
okay so the guy walks in he gets a nice
greeting from the the woman running
store kind of looks around like a
shopkin shopping and
he is shopping in us in a certain way
yeah why not grab all the jeans just
grabs a whole stack of jeans
most of those won't fit them but
[Music]
and then grab some other clothes and
walks right out
and then you always see the impotent
employee walking
after the person is left
the employee shows up in the frame on
the phone who are you who are you going
to call the ghostbusters there's no one
to call here no no one's going to no
one's going to arrest that guy no one's
going to prosecute him
and the cops won't arrest him because
he's not going to be prosecuted
and we know this problem is not
contained to san francisco similar
scenes have unfolded in chicago miami
new york los angeles all of these cities
have cut back on or entirely given up on
prosecuting so-called non-violent
criminals which has given those
criminals the green light to do what
they do best
shocking result here
apparently when you don't prosecute
certain crimes you get more of those
crimes
now these videos are generally shared by
people who are outraged by what they see
and i understand the outrage it offends
us to see scumbag criminals running amok
doing what they please with no
consequence
we want to see them punished and that is
a good and properly ordered desire it's
a desire for justice
and we should desire that
but what we should not feel is any
sympathy for the quote unquote victims
here
as mean as it might sound to say it
now it's good to feel sympathy
um
generally that's a good instinct to have
but we need to get past that in this
case
because we have to remember that the
people of california quite literally
asked for this
so yes i am victim blaming
very often victim blaming is appropriate
very often uh we find that
in many types of situations
the victims deserve the quote-unquote
victims have a certain amount of the
onus falls on them as well and that is
certainly the case here
because they went to the polls the
people of california did and they voted
on a ballot initiative to effectively
decriminalize shoplifting so this wasn't
even a case of voting for some crazy
left-wing politician who then goes and
put these puts these policies in place
that's the way it's worked in some of
these other cities and there the
citizens are getting what they asked for
too but in california
the proposal was on the ballot they
selected it
they chose it
they said yeah that sounds good i want
that
they sewed and now they
reap it sounds not only harsh but
perhaps nihilistic to say that we should
simply sit back now and let the
left-wing cities burn
but it's not nihilistic at all it's the
opposite really
we are letting people experience the
consequences of their own actions
we are letting them discover that their
actions matter their choices matter
and that is not nihilism
we are letting them have what they chose
we are allowing them to take their nice
sounding liberal theories and experience
them in reality
they're learning the hard way
because that's the only way they will
learn if they ever do it all
this is one of the reasons why i don't
understand the conservatives who were
very eager to get a republican elected
as governor in california
it was probably never going to happen
and it probably never will happen at
this point
but there are a lot of republicans there
were very they wanted to get larry elder
in there they wanted a republican
but why should we want that
why should we want a republican sitting
at the top of this dung keep
why should we want a republican
overseeing a collapsing system
no california is a left-wing dystopia
it's everything that happens when
leftists are allowed to do as they
please why should we want a republican
anywhere near that
he can't save california why should he
try
see leftism proliferates in part because
the people who support its policies and
ideas have rarely been allowed to
experience them in their fruition
we we we have we have been saving them
from themselves
we've been standing in the gap largely
because we have to live in this society
too it's one thing for them to reap
their fruits
it's another for us to reap them too
but as the sane people flee the
dystopian hellscapes like california
there is now finally an opportunity for
us to say okay have it your way do as
you please
i wish it didn't have to be this way but
it does
let them lay in the bed they've made
let california become everything they
want it to be
so that maybe they can discover that
they never really wanted it at all i
think that's the only way forward now
it's the only way
and that's why i must say that san
francisco and california are by their
own doing
officially canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show cnn puts
out a hit piece on kamal harris the
economy should be booming but it's not
and americans are noticing that's today
on the ben shapiro show give it a listen